on veut faire un film pour ça on
enlevait françois houle a pris tout son
matos
il nous a parlé de caméras
de réglage de lumière
[Musique]
je sens que ça va mal tourner mais
mon intérêt encore fini
le look cinéma
ça on en a besoin
on va les faire cracher le morceau
[Musique]
tard et avait pris tout mon matos mais
si les houthis et ma vie que comment je
vais faire moi ça va c'est bon tu as on
sait bien que c'est pas mon métier et
vidéaste mais t'es con quoi c'est
exactement ce qu'on essaie de faire
non mais je veux dire c'est pas mon vrai
métier comme tourneur fraiseur pizzaïolo
plat qui sous ostréiculteurs coiffeur
non on va de le rendre ton matos vous
avez plutôt intérêt tout tout tout tout
tout tout tout façon c'est quasiment
tous à l'avoir grâce à des blocs cinéma
lux ine
ouais
le look cinéma
[Musique]
ah ah
[Rires]
[Musique]
non nos visites et serviable ouais
attend le look cinéma c'est le truc
qu'on voit partout sur internet
ah oui ça pour faire cliquer pour vendre
du rêve je dis pas que les gens qui en
parlent fond de mauvaise image mais
c'est quoi pour vous déjà le look cinéma
bah c'est simple hyper simple et puis ta
sont ici c'est moi qui pose les
questions
moi je n'en savais rien en fait quoi
stop françois stop
trop c'est trop stop j'en ai marre de
jouer au chat et aux balles de riz
on va pas se tailler le cul en étoile
pour chier des churros alors maintenant
tu vas nous dire exactement tout ce
qu'on veut savoir sur le look cinéma
même si j'ai déjà une petite idée de la
réponse
le look cinéma c'est les deux bandes
noires en haut et en bas de l'écran
format scope tu veux dire lefranc
mascotte ces bandes noires qu'on voit
sur un film quand on regarde sur une
télévision 16/9 c'est ce qu'on appelle
le cinémascope et il ya plein de formats
différents avec des mesures différentes
on va faire simple et là où c'est
trompeur c'est qu'à la base il n'y a pas
de bandes moi c'est juste une image plus
large avec un ratio de 2 35 pour un tout
ça vient et bien le cinémascope c'est un
procédé inventé par un français du nom
de henri chrétien qui a créé le
dispositif de l'optique anamorphique en
prise de vues comme en projection appelé
hyper gonnard ce monsieur est aussi
connu pour l'invention du cinéma en
relief tout comme d'autres technologies
liées au cinéma et c'est grâce à ce
procédé qu'on appelle l'anamorphose
qu'on obtient le fameux cinémascope on
va filmer avec une optique qui déforme
l'image pour ensuite venir compressé
cette image et redonner leur forme
réelle aux choses ce qui a pour effet de
réduire la hauteur de l'image et lui
donner ce look très particulier le
cinémascope est un format qui permet de
doubler la largeur du format 4/3
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui les
meilleures caméras pour de l'anah mort
tic sont celles qui ont un capteur 4/3
pour l'anecdote même si on continue
d'appeler ça de 2,35 dans les faits en
numérique on est passé sur de 2,39 ou
même du 2 40 points
en gros si on rajoute les bernois
artificiellement en haut et en bas pour
donner ce book oui enfin ça rappelle le
cinémascope
mais ça n'en est pas d'autant plus que
tous les films ne sont pas sûrs en
format large comme celui là the
lighthouse par exemple est au format
carré ou plus récemment la version
sneijder kuyt de justice league qui est
au format 4/3 donc dans les bandes
noires seraient pas forcément cinéma
j'étais sûr pourtant que tu m'as pris
par surprise
je sais la caméra et les objectifs
c'est ça qui fait le look cinéma alors
dans le cinéma on voit souvent
effectivement de grosses caméras avec de
gros objectifs qui coûtent à eux seuls
le prix d'un appartement parisien
ces caméras et optiques participe à
donner un look mais est-ce que tu savais
que certaines scènes de captain america
avait été tourné avec un canon 5d mark
ii et on en parle de la gopro dans le
hobbit et puis au delà de ça il ya des
films entiers qui ont été tournées avec
autre chose que des super caméra d'un
écrit prend paranoïa de steven
soderbergh 100% filmé à l'iphone le
projet blair witch avec une simple
caméra dv tu sais le caméscope de papa
et récemment zack snyder a sorti un
court métrage de malades réalisé en un
week-end avec un iphone 7
ça prouve bien qu un film c'est certes
du matériel une équipe des moyens de
production mais ça ne se limite pas à ça
donc bas n'ont toujours pas là je sais
c'est la couleur locaux petit bol des
luttes
alors l'étalonnage c'est clair que c'est
une étape cruciale dans la conception du
look d'un film mais il ya tellement de
façons d'étalonner on peut avoir un
traditionnel tylane orange qu'on
retrouve dans énormément de grosses
productions il y en a tellement d'autres
regardent matrix et sa teinte verte qui
te montre bien à quel moment les héros
sont dans la matrice mad max fury road
et ses teintes ocre qui te donne
l'impression que tu toi même dans le
désert
sin city de robert rodriguez et sont
tombés dès qu'ils te plonge dans
l'univers d'un comics 300 et tellement
d'autres
et aucun de ce film a la même couleur
mais ça c'est la finition
sur les images de ces films on aurait pu
faire n'importe quel traitement de
couleur ou de contraste c'est un choix
scénaristiques autant qu'un choix
esthétiques et puis les filtres et
autres luttes c'est bien ça peut aider
mais l'étalonnage ça ne se lit pas ce
genre de choses c'est bien plus complexe
une lutte s'est figé alors qu'un film
évolue et surtout et colorisée en
fonction de ce que le réalisateur veut
faire passer comme message
bon alors tu attends quoi pour nous le
dira si tu continues à vouloir jouer au
plus malin ça va très mal se passer
françois ah bah si tu fais péter ça tu
va galérer à le faire ton film tu vois
il a compris que c'était bon d'être là
tu veux faire un film
et tu sais même pas me dire ce que cette
fois je sais pas ce que c'est le cinéma
oui sérieusement c'est encore plus long
comme ça pas fait le
à quoi cela motion haga
ça c'est cinématiques
[Musique]
alors d'abord on va définir ce qu'est le
slow motion parce que c'est un argument
marketing très important pour les
marques de caméras le slow motion c'est
en français du ralenti au cinéma on
diffuse généralement en 24 images par
seconde quand on filme à vitesse réelle
sans prévoir de ralentis on filme donc à
la même cadence 24 images par seconde
pour faire du ralenti
c'est très simple on va filmer à une
cadence supérieure 48 96 et ya même des
caméras qui filment à plus de 1000
images par seconde et ralentit tuant
retrouve dans beaucoup de films
principalement pour des scènes d'action
pour casser le rythme détail un
mouvement figer le temps est
généralement ajouter une intensité
dramatique
tiens par exemple la fameuse scène de
matrix le bullet time qui pour l'époque
était une véritable prouesse technique
puisqu'elle a demandé l'installation de
dizaines d'appareils photo n'aura pas se
mentir les ralentis sur les vidéos que
tu peux voir sur internet c'est souvent
du cache-misère
parce que ça va plusieurs avantages déjà
tu as une impression de stabilité plus
importante
ça permet d'utiliser des plans à main
levée que tu n'aurais pas pu utiliser à
vitesse réelle
ça permet également de réaliser des
mouvements de caméra style est assez
simplement mais neuf fois sur dix s'est
ralenti ne sont pas utilisés dans un but
précis c'est joli et c'est surtout très
pratique
je critique pas je le fais aussi mais
c'est pas le ralenti qui va te donner
ton cinéma
bon ça suffit maintenant les plans
stabilisateur non c'était d'icham non
plus
filtre de diffusion des filtres et de
diffusion aucun des deux les mouvements
de caméra non plus la désaturation
partiel non les titres non les
transitions les transitions transition
les transitions cinéma sérieux une
transition ce n'est pas un effet ou un
plugin avant tout les transitions c'est
un peu la ponctuation du cinéma un moyen
de passer d'un plan un autre les plus
connus sont le cut
une transition de brut d'un plan à un
autre mais qui peut être plein de sens
comme dans cette scène de the haunting
of filaos le fondu qui peut être un
fondu au noir ou un fondu enchaîné dans
lequel deux images se chevauchent mais
l'idée d'une transition c'est de passer
d'une scène à une autre en guidant le
spectateur pour comprendre l'histoire la
psychologie d'un personnage ou tout un
tas d'autres choses au cinéma même dans
les transitions et de la narration
ouais et l'esmo somme par exemple tout
le monde dit sur youtube que ça fait
cinéma attendu beaucoup des smoothies
mon cinéma tu sais ce que je pensais
tant pis j'appuie sur le bouton
bassil bah non non moi si tu déconnes un
nom aussi manon
tu m'as gtx et pas de frais pas si
[ __ ] françois lachaud lundi cela
comment on la sopie times books cinéma
non mais là vous cherchez un truc existe
ou pas le look cinéma c'est une hérésie
de dire ça y'a pas un look cinéma à la
limite si je devais donner ma définition
du cinéma ce serait ça pour moi c'est
quand tout a un sens quand tous les
éléments du choix de la caméra en
passant par l'éclairage le jeu des
acteurs le choix des optiques le décor
quand tout ça et penser c'est quand
chacun de ces éléments raconte quelque
chose et nous procurent des émotions
pour moi c'est ça qui fait le cinéma non
une séquence d'illustration ans l'homo
au milieu d'un blog sanaryenne
cinématographique
c'est pas parce que c'est beau que c'est
du cinéma et d'ailleurs ça enlève rien à
la qualité de ses vidéos et au talent de
ce qu'il réalise mais moi j'aime le
cinéma depuis toujours et même si la
définition peut varier en fonction de
chacun est une chose qu'on peut pas les
cette route le cinéma ça nous fait rire
ça nous fait pleurer ça nous fait peur
ça nous fait exhulter où ça nous met en
colère
le cinéma c'est avant tout des histoires
et des émotions et aujourd'hui on a
tendance à oublier avec tout le contenu
des réseaux sociaux on prend plus le
temps de raconter des histoires qui
qu'on soit petit ou grand s'il ya un
truc que tout le monde aime c'est qu'on
lui raconte une histoire
tous les deux vous voulez faire un film
c'est une super idée
mais est-ce que vous avez un truc à
raconter
ou est ce que vous voulez juste faire un
déballage de matos on a tout faux depuis
le début moi je pensais que tu savais un
minimum de quoi tu parles est en fait on
n'est pas prêts du tout tu as raison
on a tout faux depuis le début on a fait
le truc à l'envers oui oui
vidéo c'est
dans notre camp c'est fini on va
repartir à zéro et oublier tout ça
désolé puis vous pensé quand même pas
que j'allais faire péter une mort
bon